hello everyone it's a great day here in  Leuven is the opening ceremony of the  first event of the Grantchester amazing  place living the Mayor was here we are  very happy to receive you in a very  historic environment and and the very  old building from 1448 that makes a lot  of sense I guess I hope that it's going  to inspire you I'm very pleased as well  to have you all again in Leuven and some  newcomer players as well for the first  time and that the best may with the  players came up for drawing of lots they  chose Belgian chocolates both for the  rapid and for the Blitz and you can be  sure the players eat some of that  chocolate right afterwards and then they  went on to the autograph ceremony  signing autographs for all their great  fans  well there you have it we're all set the  players are ready to do battle it's on  to fighting chess here in Louisville  you